thank you very much
so I'm just one thing surface we did not
technically acquired it's so my name is
Alberta and I'm going to present you
today replay attacks and defenses
against crossfire consensus in Charley
distributed ledgers so this is joint
work
[Music]
[Applause]
so this joint work with a banner Mustafa
and George so we did the entire work
when we were at UCL and a chain space
but so now we joined calibra so calibra
asked us to make clear that this was
work done previously we joined but still
at at least one slide about calibra so
here you go so I removed a lot of
introductions about what our blockchains
why we are so happy to have them what
are the things we can do with that
because I assume that you kind of know
about that in same for all the
discussions about yeah BFD consensus bad
news we should have or we should not
have three because all of that has also
been discussed so we will have it a bit
more time for me to go to the
implementations of the protocol or for
you to crucify me a bit more with your
questions depending on what you enjoyed
the most so here is the problem of
blockchain scalability we imagine that
we have those nodes and they run
consensus right if we have pbft the
communication complexity would be yuan
squared I mean the happy case hot stuff
tell us yeah you can do better than that
you can do all and okay but if we had a
lot of nodes the more nodes we add and
the slowest it gets so the lot of works
are on scalability in many ways to try
to scale a little bit more those
consensus protocol right so several
approaches sharding so that's the one
that we are focusing right now but there
are many others right so these are just
not included in the talk so people may
say well we just live a happy life of
joy in half state channels and if things
go bad well we use juice the main chain
as the supreme court to settle all
disputes induced to commit things from
time to time or I mean whatever idea
like bigger blocks more broad all of
these can be played to increase
throughput or whatever so particularly
about charging this is the setting that
we work on right now for the stock so we
have lots of nodes some of them are bad
and what we do is that we separate into
subsets of shards all those nodes so
we may use run hound run herds random
allocations and so you see that here we
were find very happy because the bad
nodes are not all in one shot so maybe
they will not be happy with that
assumption but let's say this is the
setting where we're working right now so
every shard is honest and the bad no
adhara but fairly split among those
charts so how does it work so every
shard will run internally its own
consensus protocol it's one stage so
everybody here has the same view of
let's say ugh so model but still every
shard on is concerned about the object
or unspent output of its own forum so
everybody would grow with some chain so
every piece of chain together would
still represent a single shot a single
state but at some points the separation
is not perfectly clean because you may
want to use some output objects that are
among shards some are near a shard endo
shard would need to communicate with
each other and that's where all the work
in cross shards protocol stars
so this is just a quick reminder how
this should work let's say that we have
a transaction T that takes two inputs x1
that lives on short one and x2 that
lives on charge two so short with not
aware of x1 and short one is not aware
on of x2 and the transaction needs to
happen in some way that x1 and x2 get
consumed and the output objects appears
on y1 y2 and y3 respectively on its
sharp this is an example of transactions
so there are a lot of bad things that
could happen so only two possible
outcomes that are correct as we have so
yesterday it's either transaction does
not happen until we have x1 and x2 or
the transaction does happen we have
don't have x1 we don't have x2 but we
have all the output whatever other
combination is not ok so remove the
slide about that because it's about the
same of what was said yesterday so here
so we have some attacks on some of the
cross char consensus protocol which are
actually fairly new so these attacks
allowed to double spend resources or
sometimes depending on the system that
you're running if it's a contract
platform or not you Mabel to lock some
resources and it's a kind of a weak
adversary in the sense that it doesn't
need to conclude with any node it can
act as a client but sometimes it can
even be a passive observer and just
observe what's in the blockchain and it
has the ability to manipulate the
network so the network is his friend it
can relay messages reorder messages and
all these kind of things so first I need
to say those attacks are very very easy
to fix if you say look I add a
synchronous sumption for safety but as
the first biggest said yesterday this
will be disgusting and the second way
that you can easily fix those attacks is
to say well we require shards to
actually store additional state so not
only do txo but also some information
about the old state and also some
specific protocol messages that need to
come and every time that they receive a
cross your transaction well they would
need to go through the old state and
make sure that it's not a doubles man so
but since the only pool of sharding is
increasing scalability I guess that this
would be
probably more than disgusting so let's
try to have a solution that doesn't
include those two so we destroyed our
attacks in the vanilla implementation of
chain spaces on the ledger so this could
or should be applied to our of an
implementation of our system but these
are the two we know best and we have the
others in the room so I mean it's always
more fun let's see how it goes so first
a quick reminder of the cross chain at
the cross shard protocol of chain space
so this is how it works we take the same
transaction T as before so X 1 leave
some charred 1 and X 2 leaves in charge
right the client submits the transaction
to shard 1 and short you because they're
the two char that actually know about
the objects ok they run BFG internally
and they make the decision is their
objects ok does exist
I'm sequencing that we all do all other
transaction that I may have and at some
point what they do is they decide that
actually it should go through they lock
X 1 so short one locks X 1 sure to locks
X 2 and they send to each other a pre
accepts T message ok the message goes
true reach the shards sure one realized
that sure to set pre accept that himself
is that pre accept and then he says ok
that's good for me so what I do is I the
lyrics 1 and I create y1 char 2 says the
same so it deletes X 2 and creates Y 2
and then what they do is they send a
message the plan by saying look it's an
accept or good and also to char tree by
saying it's fine to me you can create
why tree and this is how it happens so
you can see that this is actually two
phase commit protocol that works again
under the assumption that every shard in
itself is honest and always live so this
protocol as liveness also because of
that reason so we may have bad nodes
inside shards but overall the char
dishonest that's why the pre accepts
come from the char right
okay and so now depending on which
messages you take and which messages you
replay you can have all sort of bad
behavior that happens if you just follow
this protocol like that so I'm not
expecting you to read that table I'm
just taking one of the examples there
which is some of them are actually very
similar and walk you through to see how
it goes so we take that example so x1 is
10 coin X 2 is 5 coin and they want to
make that transaction that recreates
those coins chart 1 or 2 & 3 so we can
say that's a very simple smart contract
the coins mark contract that just needs
to make sure what the some input equals
to some of yo the goal of the attacker
now is to in the first phase trying to
record a pre accept T message from shard
one the attack works in two phase first
it records a message and then during
another instance of the protocol
it replaced the message at a very
particular time exploiting a race
condition so first thing that the client
does it computes a bad transaction
bearing the sense that it knows that
this cannot go through so what it does
is it takes okay T prime and input X Y
x1 shells that is supposedly to be lived
on short one but actually does not exist
so it knows in advance that this will
fight any puts x2 on the on the inputs
of the same x2 as the real transaction
then takes D output on the other way so
K submits that T prime transaction
obviously sha-1 says pray abort so this
is not okay X 1 tilde is not exist
ensure - says fine X 2 exist so I send
the pre accept so which means the chart
- now locks the object likes to by the
attackers has the capability of kind of
stopping time here because you can
manipulate the network and says alright
this protocol is now stalled for a
little time and what it does it sends
transaction T so the one of before the
target transaction so what will happen
is shard one would say pre accept that's
good for me x1 exists actually but short
- we say no sorry x2 is currently locked
so for me that's a
right now so it means that find the
particular boards nothing happened
but now the attacker could record the
message pre except T sent by shard 1
then the brought the first protocol then
resumes and ok abort
so X 2 gets unlocked and that's fine
nothing happens so nothing happens but
the attacker managed to record the pre
except T from shard 1
now what the attacker does it it sends
another transaction T star that says
fine we'll just take X 1 and spend it to
some other shard or to the same char
whatever but now the IMP it doesn't
exist anymore may be transferred use the
coin to another account the old and now
I can send the transaction so what it
does is again you shard one and two
sharks you sure one says well X 1 does
not exist because you just spend UT X
all right so you just used your X 1
ensure to says well that's good to me
because I didn't spend it yet so I can
send a pre accept but now what happens
is the attacker races char 1 by sending
the pre-record that accepts G - char -
so this is not assuming synchrony so
what will happen is char 2 says well
that's the first message they received
from short one so I make progress
because my self i said pre accepts so
what will happen is they would delete X
to create y to send the message to the
client by saying that's ok sure
char 1 abort because it reminds it so
it's own decision that was saying prayer
board but still char tree may receive
depending on which ro he arrives first
well why tree and so what happens is we
spend 5 coins to create 14 coins in that
example which is
so these attacks also works in the
second phase of the atomic commit
protocol but they're much less
interesting is just that it's a bit
unclear what happens if those messages
here are repeated in the very specific
scenario where shadow tree was not part
of the first phase of the atomic commit
protocol before but those are not
interesting so I'm just skipping that
okay this is ami ledger which is very
similar so they're there those two words
have been doing more or less at the same
time so people were aware of each other
but when the paper were basically
already written so the protocol are very
similar but in the sense that now in
nominal ledger the client access
coordinator so it's not that shard 1
ensure 2 would send messages to each
other they would just channel those
messages to a client and that gives much
better performance at ran space in the
sense that they are linear in the number
of sharps so what happens to in space
that how many Roger doesn't really have
a concept of locking what it does is
that they optimistically invalidate and
if necessary they would revalidate the
object later so send the transaction as
before transaction t-chart one gets that
shot to get to they go in activate X 1
and X 2 fine
they send pre accept clients client
aggregates those messages and repeats
back it's an accept because everybody
sent for access so I didn't mention but
if any of the shards would say pre abort
well they would just send up work right
that's what's to the case formulas for
changes and so that again it can be seen
as a two-phase commit protocol
so again if you replace some of the
messages you may see some kind of bad
behavior but I just take one and go much
faster than before which is the same
transaction to show that exactly the
same thing may happen in that scenario
right so again we want to record prey
pre except T from short one we submit
the same bat transaction as before so
the goal of the transaction is just to
trigger some specific messages from the
shards right and just to record that so
we send T prime of
a delay now we repeat the protocol by
saying this transaction T exactly as
before
x2 gets invalidated but again the
attacker can record pre except from
short one the protocol says aborts so
all the protocol abort but this is
exactly as before actually the only
difference is that since the messages
are channeled to the clients well you
get better better complexity but at the
end of the day the same attack happens
to both now again you remove your x1 in
order to be able to double spend your
coins you create the first instance of
the protocol and then you race to a
client which you pre-recorded pre except
T which will then aggregate all the
messages and reflect back so now have to
say it makes little sense for an
adversary which is not the client to
attack how many ledgering that's in that
context because I mean if you have a
very kind adversary that wants to help
the clients to make more money this can
also work because now we're just double
spending the clients coins but generally
speaking the attacker would be the
client itself in that scenario
so again also attacks against the second
phase it's a bit unclear what happen if
those messages get replayed multiple
times
it's not very easy it is not trigger to
implement for counter announces since as
change base no one really knows the
state of the arishok ok the two issues
here so I'm not going to the full
details just saying quickly with what
are what are the things that causes the
problem by the way I'm seeing no
questions so normal yes also questions
here yeah two phase commit words right
two-phase commit normally works yes
process replicated thing so what's
what's wrong
two-phase commit identity those
protocols it's exactly so what are the
things indeed that could go that makes
these Iraq work despite all the
primitive in self are actually very nice
it's true that when you compose them
well they're very good ways to compose
them that but that's that what happened
so basically the problem is the input
chart cannot associate the protocol
messages so the two-phase atomic commit
messages to the instance of the protocol
of the cross yard protocol so they
cannot really know if a repaid message
come from the current instance of the
protocol or from an old one that has
just been happening in parallel so if
the problem happens at the composition
of those primitives nor it's not problem
of any of those two primitives in a per
se and the second is that the output
shards which is a I think that probably
doesn't happen in classic two-phase
atomic amid some of which are do not
take parts of the first phase over the
protocol they only take part of the
second one
it's just that they receive a message
from the input chart by saying look you
were not part of the input chart because
the input object were not your concern
but we're telling you you should create
a new object here and so generally
speaking to phase out Omega mid size I
mean you do the first phase then you do
the second phase that here we have some
players that actually do only the second
phase but not the first place in this
create a concern when you breach the
primitives it's a high level explanation
is that a little bit what you were
hoping for
well it's like it often encrypted an
identifier is missing exactly yeah
exactly so the thing why it's not very
easy to add a session identifier I mean
we did it so it's not impossible but
it's not trivial to do is because the
shards cannot know anything about the
other sharks so you cannot have a global
session identifier for your transaction
because otherwise it implies that you
actually know the state of the others
and it's not really stage hardening
anymore but we can indeed add session
identifiers yeah in such a way that we
don't want to break scalability neither
so what we did is we fixed the problem
but since we were so nicely in that way
we just said look let's have a protocol
that a little bit combined so many
ledger and chain space and fix it at the
same time because how many ledger got
better performance but it's actually
slightly easier to fix chain space and
since they're very similar we may as
well have a new one and we call it
biscuit yeah so the name is fairly
random but as any respectable a
french-speaking person I cannot
pronounce biscuits so I pronounce it
biscuits and so on
George said one day whether look it's
Byzantine so we must well change a few
letters that's the original line so
that's the we fix first the issue one of
the slide before and then the issue too
so as you mentioned the issue one we add
some session identifiers here how do we
do that so we add a sequence number to
each object so not to each chart we try
it but I mean we didn't find any obvious
solution to make it that way would have
been better but every object in itself
so this of course means the object are a
bit bigger but I mean it's a sequence
number so every time that you store an
object you also store and associate a
sequence number start with zero now what
you do is that to fix issue to the fact
that you are only some-some out which
are do not take part of the first phase
of the atomic commit protocol which says
look we will fix it in a kind of trivial
way we force everyone to char to also be
part of the input char so they will
follow all phases of the atomic commit
protocol so if you have the transaction
key that only was touching input X 1 and
input X 2 we say all right since the
output is also non char tree we will
have a dummy object that will be insert
in the transaction just for the sake of
making the protocol progress the same
for every shard so when you bootstrap a
shard it creates a fixed number of the
object which also have sequence numbers
and well when you try when you send a
transaction T I will show you in a
second it we also such one of the dummy
object of the char that then will be
created so now to send a transaction T
the client also act a little bit like
coordinator taking inspiration from
Elijah by saying it proposes the next
sequence number four all the objects
that will be touched by the protocol
so it's asked yeah so what does it it
send the transaction to all charts so
also chart three this time then they do
two things they do usual checks so you
check so it's all fine the input is
there we should go ahead but they also
check so each one does that check that
the proposed sequence number is actually
bigger than the sequence number of their
own object so this is a bit misleading
this formula there because actually
short one doesn't know the s x2 it only
knows the sequence number its own object
so everybody individually will just
check the st it's bigger than its
current sequence number and everybody
does that if they just check that it's
bigger or equal because they do they
have no idea of if the sequence number
of other people would actually be bigger
if the protocol fail so if anybody needs
to say abort well in any cases you
update the sequence number so you
updated to st plus one not just two plus
one otherwise that still replay attack
possible in this forces the sequence
number to be monotonically increasing
since you will not go back with the
sequence numbers well then it means that
I mean intuitively means that you cannot
really replay the internal messages and
you can use those sequence number a
session identifier and that's the
classic way of fixing the replay attacks
so we have a theorem proof but I mean
it's probably better to explain that way
so what you do is as usual you lock x1
so charm unlocks x1 char two blocks x2
and sure to lock these dummy objects so
because you need to lock an input as
well and what they do they don't simply
say you're right those objects are
locked but they lock by saving s T and T
the transaction as a pair so they know
that now those objects are not only
locked in general but
not for that particular instance of the
prodigal and this is what acts a session
identifier so now this is the little
difference that we have with respect to
train space and only ledger which kind
of similar in the same way sure it's
well so in space said you send the pre
exit messages to all the error messages
omni ledger says well you can send it to
the client to the client it will
aggregate and we'll be more efficient
the thing is it makes total sense to
rely on the client to do this
aggregation if you only have coins in
your system because we may say sure the
client has some incentive to make the
protocol progress and for its own
transaction at the very least because
he's the one that wants to spend its own
time but it's not specifically true or
at least not obvious to me if that's the
case if you have a general smart
contract platform in the sense imagine
that you have an object that is at depth
in not really a coin you may want to not
make the protocol progress right so we
say we have an external party we call it
TM the transaction manager I'll come to
that in a minute to see who is actually
that gem that will act as the omni
ledger clients aggregate and send back
the messages so what do the output chart
do well if everything goes through they
first need to check that indeed they
lock the transaction for that particular
pair of SD empty and then they delete
the inputs and they create the output
and note that about a dummy object you
also deleted and since it was a dummy
object you recreate a new one because
you always want a fixed supply of a
dummy object so there is a little detail
that I'm overlooking here is that these
dummy object editor they limit your
concurrency a little bit because you can
have a fixed supply can be big sure but
this is still the maximum number of
transaction that the shark could the
handle at the same time
so this is also to face that let me
commit just composed a little bit better
so who is that p.m. now well this is an
insight that comes from the Omni ledger
paper which is probably maybe it does
not be emphasized enough but actually
these guys repeated as a few times
before that is to say look actually it
doesn't really matter what Greg eighths
the message it works STM because it
doesn't act on any secret
it's actually an operation that see some
messages sign you don't need to use any
secret on your own you just aggregate
and send it back to the right people
right so it means that this GM can
actually be anybody
we may say let's say that it's one
single party and if that party does not
make progress where we we hope that one
honest good Samaritan in the system will
come pick up realize that song that the
protocol has not completed and what
complete the protocol needs to be held
or we might say look we pick a shard we
choose a sharp and what we do is we
select a certain number of node or maybe
one node in the shard and we try to use
him as a TM if it doesn't work we pick
the next one and so the next one and
eventually we pick the F plus one and
that node should be good and should
allow the TM to make progress but I mean
those are all possibilities no really
important we know that in any case under
potential difference assumption we will
make progress in the protocol
and so how does this prevent replace
attack so as I said before the problem
was a butcher cannot associate protocol
messages the specific instance
well now the session ID solves a problem
that's very classic in the literature
and the second problem that outputs are
do not experience the full two-phase
atomic amid the juice the second phase
well now we force them to participate in
the first phase so there is no attack
surface in that way anymore
so yeah the code is open source now I
can either go slightly to the
performance over and over time I don't
know it'd be great if you stop and do
yep
[Applause]
yeah how do you ensure that every
committee has for every shot has honest
majority or honest - yeah that's the
setting in which we the setting in which
we work and in which Omni ledger and
chain space work that's I mean it's not
something that's sorry that would be
much lower than usual
I mean the best description on these
it's actually on the beginning of the
Omni ledger paper that basically says
that you have you use distributed
randomness that's how you attribute
notes to shards and that number of nodes
that you need in order to have I mean
good probability for these things that
you mentioned do not happen but here
it's an assumption we work under that
assumption and that's it
all right
[Applause]